our next speaker is a phd dropout
and right after he dropped out of his
phd he moved to dc and was a segway tour
guide
and he felt the need to constantly
apologize to all the dc natives for
blocking their way with segways so
please welcome
alex to the stage
thanks so much for being here uh today
and uh for coming to talk about reliably
reproducible artifacts i was so proud
when i thought of this like i probably
should have thought of it a long time
ago but i was really proud of this pun
um so again my name is alex i'm a
manager on the solutions engineering
team at our studio um you can tweet at
me at alex k gold and the slides and
other stuff are not currently but will
be available um on my website at alex k
gold.space
speaking
um
so we're gonna start off just talking a
little bit about reproducibility and and
what's up with reproducibility and then
we'll get into some like real
nitty-gritty how and why we're gonna try
and get through rn our studio package
manager and docker in the next
19 minutes and 30 seconds so like buckle
up it's gonna be a wild ride all right
so
why should we care about reproducibility
in in general and you know the the
obvious answer here is that like you
want to share with others or with future
you
um and that's that's a really common
reason the other answer and this is
often true particularly if you're in
like a heavily regulated or a government
industry is like you don't have an
option right like you just
have to make things reproducible you
have archival and reproducibility
requirements that that you have to meet
and so like what what is reproducibility
i i think of these three as synonyms as
like reproducible self-contained
portable are like those are those are
all sort of uh you know uh uh
intermingled to to me in terms of how i
think about reproducibility and so then
the question becomes like
you know how do i make things reduceable
and and first it's important to think
about like how reproducible does
something need to be right things can be
sort of not at all reproducible right
like you can never run it again it's
never gonna work again that's obviously
probably
bad for the most part unless it's like
really a one-off kind of thing it could
be like somewhat reproducible right like
it runs but you've got to spend some
time sort of getting it up and running
and like there are conditions where like
it would probably break in the future or
you could get to like fully reproduce
which i think is usually an illusion but
like you know way really reproducible
and and you know you can move up the
spectrum of reproducibility but also the
thing is as things get more reproducible
they they get to be it's more work it's
harder to be more reproducible and so
it's worth thinking about for the
projects you're working on what's the
right level of reproducibility for the
thing
you're um you're you're working on uh
you know again oftentimes for um things
with the the government or with the
public sector um or with um
you know regulated industries that you
don't have an option but sometimes you
do and you have to choose the sort of
appropriate spot to be on on the
spectrum
i think about reproducibility for data
sciences falling along sort of like
there are three
um three things and i have to say that
this is the only pie chart that has ever
appeared in a presentation of mine and
it is purely to have three colors on the
screen so you know don't don't hate me
too bad uh but the the the three uh sort
of components of reproducibility for
data science i think is being the code
right can your actual code be
reproducible uh does it run
um things like setting random numbers
right do you have a stable way to get
random numbers into your code where you
need them uh data can you get the same
data through your code over and over
again or or does your data sort of
change every time you run your your code
and the environment uh can you actually
set up a place where your code can run
that's reliable and today for the
purpose of this talk we're really just
talking about the environmental piece
the code and the data there's lots and
lots of good
tools and writing and resources out
there i highly recommend you check them
out that's that's not what we're talking
about
so we're going to start talking at the
level of our packages and and
reproducing your r package environment
so let's let's take a hypothetical set
of three interconnected packages you
might use in your analysis so we'll say
we have the packages b player and tidy s
they have a dependency that they share
on s lang so when i go install that
package b player tidy s i get all of
them in my in my project let's say for
the sake of argument all version 1.0
well now some time passes and i need to
do this again or somebody else needs to
do this on their machine um you know
some sometime later like what versions
am i gonna get with i install that
packages doesn't specify versions and so
i i don't know and this is bad right
this is a bad place to be uh it's very
irreproducible and i would say this is
sort of like the bottom level of
reproducibility right so the first level
uh is to just get those packages those
package versions recorded so that they
can be sort of stably restored and the
way to do that is with the rn
package um and this does does two things
it creates a lock file for archiving and
sharing and a project library to protect
projects one from from the other and
we'll talk a little more about this in a
minute
at the next level right what happens if
i archive a project i need to resurrect
it years later so let's say let's go
back to this project i had i used rn so
i've got my project i still have s line
b player and tidy s 1.0 in them and i
come back two years later and i want to
install say ee plot floor for the
popular plotting library
and at this point ee plot4 has moved
along so it's at version 1.2 and but
that pulls in s lang 1.2 and i don't
know rb player and tidy s gonna run like
uh oh that's that's bad
um and so we're gonna talk about our
studio package manager repository
snapshots as a way to fix this this
problem
and so so far like you know you've got
your code we talked about how to
reproduce the layer of r and python
packages and i'll demonstrate it a
little bit that we're not done with that
but but we've you know rn package
manager snapshots but like there are
more things down the stack you might
have to reproduce for example your
versions are in python your system
libraries your operating system itself
in some really highly regulated
industries you need to go all the way to
the layer of the hardware if you need to
do that like i don't have any solutions
for you you need to keep a server for 20
years and like that's on you and your
itt
but if you don't need that
you might be able to get some help
from docker right docker is a really
popular uh solution here um it's a tool
for creating saving and quickly
restoring computational environments um
the biggest benefit of docker is that
you can sort of like take a whole
computational environment save it and
then bring it back months days weeks
years later all you need to do is make
sure that your your host has docker you
don't need to worry about any of the
other things they'll all be
in the container and i'll show you this
in a little bit but the there are other
ways to create virtual environments
docker's biggest advantage is it's very
lightweight it's very uh uh sort of fast
to start and we'll see that in a little
bit
um before we we head into like demoing
things i just want to talk a little
about docker because people here are
probably less familiar with with docker
than some of the other components that
are you know are specific
so just to give like a quick simple
mental model on docker uh you have a
docker file that's code that tells your
computer how to build a docker thing
you build that docker file into a docker
image so a docker image you can think of
as like a bunch of compiled code it's
like a dot exe right it's like it's
there it's ready to run it's good to go
but it's not sort of anything on its own
it's just the image and then you run a
docker image as a container so a running
docker thing is the running container um
the the image is the sort of frozen
snapshot and the file is the code that
it comes from there is a little
terminology here right like sometimes
people refer to all of this as the
container you know sort of generally
referring to it as the container uh but
but it's good to differentiate from a
running container versus an image that
is not running but is ready to be a
running container
okay with that let's go to some demo
i'm actually going to stop sharing and
re-share my other screen
and
let's pull up our studio
okay um so here's what we're gonna do
we're going to start a new project we're
gonna go all the way from new project to
docker container in how much time do i
have left
12 minutes we got it we're gonna hit it
all right new directory new project i'm
starting a new project here in um
in our studio i'm going to use rn for
those of you who haven't used rn before
um rn works really nicely to isolate
project libraries and help you archive
them and save them later so to like give
you a very concrete image of what rm
does if i type library
our markdown
well it's not going to work if i missed
if i misspell it but if i spell it
correctly even there's no our mark down
package in here even though i've
installed our markdown dozens of times
on my computer and that's because rn
creates an isolated project library now
this isn't a big deal because now if i
go install.packages
uh and i'm going to do a few packages
that i know i'm going to need here just
get them all uh our markdown
mime
and markdown
what you'll see is this install is going
to be almost instantaneous and that's
because rn
keeps a cache uh of different libraries
across my um
uh uh across all of my projects and so
that's why that install was almost
instantaneous there which is which is
pretty nice i i like that feature
um so now that i've got my my rn project
i've got the libraries i need here um i
could for example let's bring in our
markdown notebook
my markdown i'm just using the hello
world one here because it's good enough
for for what i'm trying to demo and
we'll call it my markdown dot rmd and
we'll save it here
but now let's take a look at the rm.log
file the rm.log file is the key to this
whole operation uh so what you'll see is
that it's recorded the version of r that
i use that's 402 here so if i need to
get back to it later i know what version
i need uh it records the repository that
i got the packages from so that can help
me restoring packages later um and it
records the actual packages i've used
now what you'll notice is that there's
almost nothing here just just rn itself
and that's because i haven't actually
used anything i have my markdown
document um but if i want rm to
recognize that i have to do the rn and
let me make this window a little bigger
so that you can read it more easily even
if it gets a little scrunchy uh i do an
rn snapshot and so what rm snapshot is
going to do is it's going to add
all of those packages that i need right
it's going to sort of look through all
these files identify the dependencies
trace out all the dependency trees and
add them all
to my to my little lock file here so now
they're all documented and you can see
you've got the version the repository so
now if i take this and i give this to
somebody else right they can restore all
these packages in their environment as
well with a simple rn restore command
and they get back the same package
environment boom level one
reproducibility achieved
so this is like minimal to me minimal
package reproducibility just use rn
it's good it works really nicely use rn
okay let's say we want to sort of take
things to the next level and remember
that issue that we had where okay now if
i come back in a year and i want to
install ggplot2 right by default what
i'm going to get is the current version
of ggplot2 that is current
a year in the future and i don't know if
that's compatible with the packages i
have now and that that's not good right
i want to be able to install something
that if i want another package in the
future i know it's going to work okay
with with this set there are also places
where you may need to audit right like
where did that set come from and and uh
you know just saying that i took what
was latest on crayon at the time right
and that's what that's what this means
not good enough
so in order to to get around that what
i'm going to do is i'm going to use a
snapshot of repository
if i can move my
um
sorry give me one sec my window out of
the way
so i'm going to use rstudio package
manager and so what arts view package
manager does here and this is our public
our studio package manager
packagemanage.rt.com
i can choose a dated repository so i'm
going to choose today
and you can see this this repository
it's packagemenodr2.com it's the
repository everything and it's today's
date plus like this hash thing that has
to do with the time of day and that sort
of thing uh and so now if i copy this
i'm just going to copy this from package
manager
and i'm going to bring it into rn and
just put it here on that repository line
boom
now at any point in the future if i'm
inside this project and i install into
this project i will always be locked to
today's date which is a really good
thing right because then i know that my
packages will work together nicely in
the future which which is really great
um so now okay so level two achieved
right so now i have a set of packages
that i know go with this project i can
share it across projects
and just one thing to note is that when
you share rm does some smart things with
git ignores so for example if i were
just to add this whole
folder to my git repository the rm.lock
file would get added and almost nothing
else
excuse me
which is really handy because the lock
files right i want to share the the lock
file so other people can reproduce the
same library i don't want to show the
actual library because for example what
if we're going across across operating
systems or something like that i don't
want to just share the library i want to
show the lock file
okay so then what we did right is we
went to a snapshot
crayon repository from our studio public
r studio package manager um and what
that does is that ensures that in the
future i will always be able to get
packages that are sort of concordant
with the current state of my library
okay now here's where things are gonna
get crazy we're gonna head into docker
territory
so we talked a little bit about a docker
file and what that would do so let's
let's pull up a docker file so this is a
docker file
um and
like every docker file it starts with a
from statement so this is like what is
the base docker image in this case we're
starting with a very very like this is
the base of the base right it's just a
ubuntu uh operating system image it has
almost nothing in it it's like got
ubuntu and like nothing else like you
can see for example here i'm installing
vim and curl it has nothing in it
so that's what i'm doing i'm taking this
this very basic docker image i'm
installing some system libraries and i'm
installing r now for the purposes of
this like if i were just doing this
actually in real life i would probably
just use like the rocker images if
you've never used them before there's a
an organization called rocker or
r-o-c-k-e-r you can google rocker docker
and they make our docker images for the
community they're awesome and you should
probably use those if you're doing
something as simple as this just some
system libraries and a version of our
but you know what i want to point out
here is that if you have specific system
libraries you have version constraints
you need to put in right you can do this
yourself it's it's not very hard to
build this docker file
so or to make this docker file so this
is my docker file this is my base image
um so now what i want to show so now
let's let's uh before
before this i compiled this into an
actual image right so remember the image
is the actual uh sort of compiled
version of this docker file so if i do
docker images and i'm going to look at
just the ones that are relevant to today
because i have oh i gotta go to the
terminal console r doesn't know what to
do with command like docker images
um
i'm gonna go docker images dcr
star
and so what you'll see is i have uh uh
this dcr base image which is that one
we'll get into these others in just a
sec although hopefully we won't need
backup
um so you know i've got this image now
and so i can do now docker run
uh dcr 2021 face great so now what's
happening is this image is coming up
it's running and then it's going back
down and but nothing happened that
that's fine right because there's
there's nothing to do here right it's
just it's an environment it's ubuntu it
has some system libraries it has an r it
has r in it but like nothing happens so
that's totally fine that's great
um i can also the other thing that you
can do is you can run docker containers
in interactive sessions so if i want to
docker run uh it dcr 2021 base you don't
need to memorize this if you google it
how to run a docker interactive like
you'll you'll find it pretty quick
uh bash
and so now i've got a terminal right
into the running docker container and so
like this is a case where even if the
container to do anything by itself right
you can see this is r402 that i've got
in the container this might be useful um
in case you're kind of tripped out yes
this is trippy to be running r in the
terminal in a docker container from
inside our studio that is weird
um
now we're out of the document
okay so now let's talk about how we're
going to archive this particular project
so we've got our markdown document here
and let's open up i have another docker
file that's sort of a project level doc
or not a project like a an app an app a
doc level docker file
um and we're going to pull that into
this project
we're going to pull it into the project
i told you before the talk that i was
going to live on the edge and do all
this live while i also had
uh hop in running and uh hopefully that
won't bite me in the butt
okay uh let's rename this for some
reason it keeps trying to name it
dockerfile.occur file which is not a
thing
cool so now i've got this this docker
file that is specific to this piece of
content and actually while i'm talking
um i'm going to
um
have this
build so that you can sort of see how
this works uh dcr doc
okay so that's gonna build
uh
dot
that's gonna build in the background oh
and i forgot that this is called my
markdown in the file name gotta make
sure that's up to date
it's gonna build for real this time uh
so you can see that that's all happening
in the background so here's what this
docker file does it starts from that dcr
2021 base it copies in that rm.log file
and my my you know markdown file as a
doc r d
right now it's installing the rn package
itself to sort of get itself ready to
to go
and then it's going to run an rn restore
which is going to pull all of those
outside packages in
uh and and get them running um this is
already running about twice as long as
it has any time in practice on this step
so i have a feeling we may have to
resort to the backup but i can let it
run for a few more seconds um you can
see in this uh in this docker file i
have it do something though this cmd
command means do a thing and in this
case it's going to run an r markdown
render and render
my uh our markdown document all right
it's taking 50 seconds just to install
rn we're going to stop that we're going
to use the backup here um
and so
uh
i'm going to create a new folder for my
results
and then i'm going to
run my docker container
and what this this part is going to do
is going to pipe the results into this
pipe the the results from inside the
container out into my my results folder
um the main thing i'll write just to
remind right the reason this is going to
do anything is this command line this
says docker when you run
actually do a thing so let's let's hit
it it's running
and what you're seeing is it's running
this arm arc down render and the main
thing to notice here the people reason
people love docker the results right
that was a new folder i just created
it's got some stuff in it now the the
main thing i just want to note is that
like that ran almost as fast as running
our markdown document locally and this
is why people love docker because
um you can run stuff almost as fast in
in a docker container as just like
knitting in the in the ide and that's
pretty awesome that i just stood up a
standalone development environment um
and and still you know could could do
that uh uh in in the docker container
and then it took almost no extra time
so i know i'm right up here at time
that's what i wanted to show and so a
couple little last things thank you
first thanks for for tuning in um so uh
uh reproducibility happiness rn
repository snapshots docker so good
um if you're interested in this kind of
thing you think this kind of thing is
cool i am working on a book called
devops for data science uh you can read
a draft there are a few draft chapters
there it's supposed to be out in june so
i've got a little time but working on it
um and then lastly i'm hiring on my team
if you think this stuff is cool you're
really interested in the intersection
between sort of uh administration and uh
data science please reach out twitter is
probably the best way to get me i'm
happy to talk the other kind of folks
we're looking for is we're looking for
managers on my team
so people who particularly if you've led
a data science team maybe done a little
bit of admin stuff
and are really excited about sort of
growing people and growing teams i would
love to talk to you please reach out
twitter is the best way to get me so
thanks